reaction now from Iraq to the attacks on
Kurdish targets from Iran Ali Hashem is
live in Baghdad for us and what's the
response been there
welcome to the moment there is no
official statement from the Iraqi
government with respect to these attacks
it's been like five days now since the
Challenger started the Iranians saying
that it's related to Kurdish separatist
group trying to infiltrate their borders
or smuggle arms into into Iran however
today was a bit significant with a
number of casualties being reported by
Kurdish officials till the moment there
are several people injured and there are
at least two killed as we understood
from the news reports we were following
so this is for now the situation the the
the challenges in different areas as I
said five days of shellings today there
were different areas shelled and
according to the Iranians these are
positions or bases that are
for the kumala group which is a Kurdish
separatus group and and other also all
the militant group that's fighting from
the Iraqi borders so at least for now
this is what we have there are
expectations that the number of
casualties might raise as we heard from
the Kurdish officials
and Iraq's Parliament is meeting for the
first time since the recent series of
protests today isn't it
well yes and it seems that today is the
beginning of the the new escalation in
the Iraqi political scene as we can see
these people behind me are pro uh
supporters who are today protesting in
tahrir square and this protest is
related to the Parliamentary session
that's expected to vote the parliament
is expected to vote on the resignation
of the parliament speaker Mohamed
Muhammad
Ally but it seems is trying to inch
himself away from this Alliance in order
to to join the Rival Alliance and this
is
prompting these uh
protesters to come to the streets mainly
here in Tahir Square the numbers aren't
quite big but over the the coming hours
maybe this number will get big figure
there were some some attempts by the
protesters to throw stones on the
security forces in order to cross to the
uh what they what was known here as
al-jumuria a bridge however the security
forces uh prevented them from from doing
that of course now we this is the end of
September by into three days the first
of October is is uh the day when uh
there are going to be widespread
protests in Iraq to commemorate the
anniversary of the October 2018 2019
that we protests and this this same
square tahriya square is expected to be
full of people okay thank you so much
for that update that's Ali Hashem in
Baghdad for us